PETE FRISELLA: Hi, everybody.
My name's Pete Frisella.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Analytics team.
I'd like to introduce you to a
new series we have called "Off
the Charts." This series is
about getting into the deep
features of Google Analytics,
understanding how it works,
things you can do with it, and
how to use the feature itself.
So today, I'd like actually
talk to you about getting
started with cost data upload,
and this is all about
measuring non-Google
paid campaigns.
So let's talk about what
is cost data upload.
I'll kind of get into little bit
more about what that means
and what cost data upload works,
how it works and the
feature itself.
Then we'll go into the
architectural overview, which
explains the deep details and
also how you would actually go
about uploading data to
Google Analytics.
And then finally, we'll talk
a little bit about some
opportunities that are available
from a developer
perspective and also from
a business perspective.
So with that, we'll
get started.
So what is cost data upload,
and what does
cost data itself mean?
So this is all related to all
the paid campaigns you may be
running out there, all the
information that's related to
that paid campaign.
Whether it be ad costs, clicks,
impressions, the name
of the campaign, all this itself
relates to cost data.
It's what we refer to as cost
data in Google Analytics.
So for example, if you are
running a campaign, say with
Google AdWords, for example,
you'll know this is pretty
familiar for you.
You've got cost data, and if
you link that to Google
Analytics, which is what you
should be doing, you actually
get these reports within
Google Analytics that
highlight, for your paid
campaigns, how they're
performing.
And they give you a lot more
information around how to
optimize certain key words,
maybe landing page
optimization.
Now, these things are important
things, but to
really do this analysis, you
need that cost data associated
with the campaigns that you're
running in Google AdWords.
And this linking works really
well today, and it takes care
of all that for you.
And it gives you some powerful
tools to take care of analysis
around campaigns and user
interaction, and how campaigns
are performing.
The thing is, though, for
a lot of people, why we
encourage you to use Google
AdWords, we love Google
AdWords, obviously.
There is other paid campaign
services out there that people
obviously use, and that includes
things like other
paid search services.
You might be running in a
campaign on a social network.
You might be doing email
marketing campaigns.
So all of these campaigns are
running out there, and you're
getting users visiting your
website or your property from
these paid campaigns,
and that's great.
You're able to track what
they're doing, the conversions
possibly that are taking place,
goal completions.
And you're getting a good
general sense of which paid
campaigns are driving traffic
to your site.
This is great.
So a report like this, that I'm
showing here right now, is
kind of common that you're
looking at, for my particular
campaigns, how are they
performing and what kind of
traffic is coming to my site
because these campaigns?
Now, you see that first row
there, row number one, is a
Google AdWords campaign.
And you'll notice while you
have user interaction data
such as visits, and you have
impressions and clicks cost
data, you don't get the same
kind of visual in cost data
that you would have
for AdWords.
You don't get the same data for
the other paid campaigns
that you may have.
So for example, we have an
AdWords network campaign
running, and we have
an affiliate
network campaign running.
And you'll see, we know people
are coming to the site, but we
don't have the cost data within
GA to do that analysis.
There's kind of two things
missing around this then.
For the particular paid campaign
itself, being able to
analyze that in terms of the ROI
and the metrics you might
be getting.
Click-through rate, cost per
click, things like that, you
kind of miss out on that.
And then also, you don't really
have the ability to
compare how these services are
performing against each other.
So is the AdWords network
driving more?
Better conversions, or is Google
AdWords driving better
conversions?
So you're missing that kind of
complete view, that complete
analysis, around your cost data
across all your different
paid campaigns that you might
be having for all online
advertising and digital
marketing.
But cost data kind of
solves that problem.
When we launched this feature
about a month ago, we had some
success stories right off the
bat with a couple customers,
working with partners of ours to
get something in place and
a solution for them.
So, for example, we talked Next
Analytics and Cardinal
Path, and they came up
with a solution that
uses cost data upload.
And they worked with
Natural Wellbeing.
And really, it was around fully
automating this process
for them, so being able to
take their cost data
automatically, export it, and
upload it into Google
Analytics using this
new feature.
And it worked really well for
them in saving them a lot of
time and doing this
full automation.
We also did the same thing with
ShufflePoint and E-Nor.
They came up with a solution
using cost data upload again
to help OEMPCWorld.
And this one was really about,
again, fully automation.
And a lot of the analysis they
were doing was kind of a
manual process where you had
your Google AdWords data, you
had some other campaigns.
You had to manually bring that
stuff together and do analysis
outside of GA.
So this new feature really
allowed them to bring all that
into Google Analytics and to
do that complete analysis
within the product itself.
So it saved them a lot of time,
fully automated, a great
solution for them.
So I think it would be good just
to start off with a quick
demo to show you how this
actually works.
And then we're going to dive
into details, and I can give
you a little bit more background
on how these actual
steps that involved
to do this.
Sometimes, it's just easier to
show you how it works, so I'll
start off with a report.
This is within Google
Analytics.
It's a custom report, and the
example here is that I have a
paid search ad running, and
it's for an ad network.
It's a CPC, and it's
for the keyword
"dogbone." And I can see--
so I've tagged my URLs,
and I'll get into that
a little bit later.
So I know that someone's
clicked on the URL, and
they've visited my property,
and I can see that there's
been two visits.
But just as how I described
before, we don't have
any cost data here.
But the thing is, I actually
do have the cost data.
The service provider that
I'm using allows me to
export the cost data.
I just don't have it in
GA, so that's really
what I want to do.
I want to have that same data
available in GA so I can do
analysis and can carry
out cost analysis.
So just something to note
here, the source is Ad
Network, the medium is CPC, and
the keyword is "dogbone."
So as I mentioned, I actually
do have this cost data.
So you can imagine that I
exported this from the paid
search provider and have
it in CSV file.
And there's a header up here
that has some dimensions that
I'll explain later.
But in row two, we can see the
same values that I just showed
you in report are
actually here.
We have Ad Network as a source,
CPC is our medium, and
we have this keyword
here, "dogbone."
And there's that cost data
I was talking about.
We have impressions, we have
clicks, and we have ad cost,
so I have this data.
It's there.
It's available, and there
was a couple other
keywords that I ran also.
Now, let's actually upload it
and see how this process
works, and then we'll see--
once it's available in the
report, you'll see how it's
actually joined together.
So I have a little script.
It's a Python script, just to
kind of test things and see
how it's working, how
the feature works.
I'll start off with--
there's this new entity called
custom data source.
I can also explain what this
means in a little bit, but
basically, you upload the cost
data to a custom data source,
and you specify which date
you'd like to upload
the cost data for.
So, in this example, this cost
data actually is from
yesterday, so I exported all of
the cost data and metrics
from yesterday into a
CSV file, and it's
available to upload.
So I'm going to select the
custom data source that I want
to upload to.
And I'll show you how
this process works.
So I have quite a few
accounts here.
I want to upload to the
My Store account.
I will select the web property,
and then here's what
I'm talking about in terms
of custom data sources.
I have three set up, and I'm
just going to choose the first
one, the Ad Network custom
data source.
So now I've selected it.
If I go back up, you'll see
now that it's actually
selected, here, Ad Network, and
then also the account and
the web property.
And then the upload data again
is 2012, November 28.
So I will do an upload of
cost data, which is
number three here.
I know the file that I showed
you, what the name of it is.
Oops.
Spelled that wrong.
OK, so it's actually uploading
right now to Google Analytics
to that customer data source,
and if all goes successful,
we'll get a response back
from the server
saying it was a success.
So it takes a little bit of
time to process the data.
It's not going to show
up instantly.
I will go back to the
presentation.
It could take anywhere from a
few minutes to up to 12 hours,
so you should see data
within 12 hours.
Depending on the kind of load
and your profile and web
property, it could take
a little longer.
I'm going to actually go back
to the presentation.
We've successfully uploaded
cost data.
I'll come back a little bit
later, and we'll see if it's
available in the report and
if it's been joined
to our actual campaign.
In the meantime, let's talk
about architectural overview,
how this feature works, and
how you would actually go
about uploading cost data.
So there's quite a few steps
involved, but they're all
pretty simple.
The first four are really around
how to prepare for a
successful upload.
And the fifth is really around
reporting and how you would do
analysis, the tools that are
available for that within GA.
We'll start with tagging
campaign URLS.
So obviously, the primary
benefit to this feature is
that you're able to join that
user interaction data that's
already in GA that you have, and
you're able to join that
with the cost data that might
sit somewhere externally.
So bringing those two together
is really a huge benefit here.
But in order to do that, it's
important that you use
campaign tracking parameters,
so you should
be doing this anyways.
But the important part of this
is that the campaign tracking
parameters, the values you use
as part of the campaign,
should or have to match the
values that you're uploading
through cost data
upload feature.
So I'll explain a little bit
more in detail what this
means, but basically, they have
to match, and if they
match, then they'll actually
get joined
together in that case.
So in this example here,
I have an ad running.
It's not a Google ad.
It's another paid
search provider.
The link there actually has UTM
parameters as part of it,
these campaign tracking
parameters, and I've specified
an ad network, CPC as a medium,
the campaign is summer
sale, and again the term is
"dogbone." So you've seen
these values throughout, and
we'll kind of explain how this
all works now.
OK, so you've tagged
your URLs.
All your destination URLs
for all your paid
campaigns are tagged.
And again, this is not
for Google AdWords.
Google AdWords has a different
mechanism for
uploading cost data.
You just link your profile to
your Analytics account, and
it'll take care of itself.
This is for non-Google paid
campaigns, just something to
keep in mind.
But once you've tagged those
URLs, the next thing you want
to do is actually get the data
out of the external source and
prepare it as a CSV file to
upload, so let's take a look
at what that means.
The first thing is what can
you actually upload.
So there's quite a few different
dimensions and three
metrics that you can
provide values for
through cost data upload.
There's actually nothing new
here in terms of dimensions
and metrics.
So these use existing AdWords
dimensions and metrics that
you've seen and are probably
familiar with, so
it's nothing new there.
So if you have any reports set
up, like custom reports around
performance of paid campaigns,
those don't have to be changed
once you start uploading
cost data.
Any zero values that you had
before will just automatically
be populated with this data
that you've uploaded.
For the dimensions, there are
two that are required, which
are source and medium.
And then for metrics, there's
three of them,
and only one is required.
One of the three is required.
For any ones that are omitted,
we'll just assume it's a value
of zero basically for those.
So this is the important
part here.
We talked about the tagging
of the URLs, and
this is why it's important.
This is how the data
actually gets
joined and mapped together.
So you have all your user
interaction data sitting in GA
already today, and you're doing
that through normal
measurement that you've already
done all the time, so
that's taken care of.
Now, you're uploading
cost data.
And what's going to happen
is the campaign tracking
parameters, the values you use
there and the ones you upload,
if there's a match there,
then the data
will get joined together.
This is why it's important that
these things are synced
across the two.
Also, there is a specific case
in terms of the case that is
required for these things.
The keyword is case
insensitive.
So it doesn't matter if the
keyword is capitalized or not,
they'll get joined regardless.
But the other four dimensions
are case sensitive, so you've
got to be careful there and
make sure these values are
consistent in that regard.
Also, it's up to you really
to determine the naming
conventions that are used
in the external system.
It's quite possible that the
naming convention used by this
external source might be a
little bit different and not
as matched up with the namings
that we use for our
dimensions within GA.
So it's kind of up to you to
look at what's available from
the external provider and map
and see how that maps these
dimensions and the values you
need to provide for these
dimensions.
It's kind of up to
you to do that.
And usually, it's a one-step
kind of process once you've
got it setup.
Then you don't have to really
worry about it anymore, but
identifying those mappings at
first is really important.
OK, so we know what
we can upload.
Let's take a look at actually
what you would upload.
So I showed you a
CSV file before.
Here's another example.
So this is for aggregates,
right?
You're uploading aggregate
data on a daily basis.
That's usually the
typical use case.
So best practice then is really
to wait until the end
of the day and then
upload cost data.
Or upload cost data for the
previous day because you want
to upload it in an aggregate,
and you upload it for a
specific date.
You say I'm going to upload it
for yesterday or the day
before and so on.
Again, you'll notice here that
the values I have for the
source and medium match the
values that I use in my URLs
for my campaigns as part of
the campaign tracking
parameters, and those should
always be consistent.
And then you have your actual
metrics here, the cost data
itself, the compressions,
ads, and clicks.
In this case, I provided values
for all three because I
had them available.
And then, of course, you saw the
list of all the dimensions
that are available.
Those can be included also.
There is quite a few different
constraints and requirements
around what needs to be provided
and the values you
can provide.
These are all available on our
developer site, which I
provide some links later
for you guys.
OK, so we've tagged our campaign
URLs with campaign
tracking parameters.
We've got our CSV file that we
exported out from the external
source, and we've prepared
it properly.
And now we have to create
a data source.
Remember, we have to upload
to a custom data source.
We have to create that, and
that's actually done through
the web interface.
OK, so I'll show you how it
actually is done right now,
and then I'll explain how
exactly that this works.
So it's at the web
property level.
And we're currently doing white
listing, so some of you
may have this, some of you may
not, but it will be all rolled
out to everybody in the next
week or so I think.
So if you go to the web property
level in the admin
panel, you'll see a tab called
Custom Definitions.
So I already have three
custom data sources
available in here.
I'm going to create a new
one, so I'll show
you how it's done.
So a new custom data source, You
can imagine just, say, I
want to have one for, let's say,
email marketing, so I'll
put email marketing campaigns,
specify the type.
We're uplinking cost data.
That's the type.
And then we link your profile.
Linking profiles will enable
this cost data to be available
for those profiles.
You can imagine you might
have 100 profiles here.
You can select which
ones you want.
There's a little search box to
make it a little bit easier.
And then you just select which
profiles you would like the
cost data to show up in.
Click Create, and you'll see now
I have a new custom data
source for email marketing
campaigns.
And the important thing here
is there's an ID, and you
actually need that ID to do
uploads, and I'll show you how
that's done.
I'm going to go back to
the presentation.
So let's look at what's a custom
data source, and how
does it relate to Google
Analytics model?
I think you're probably mostly
familiar with this.
This is the way GA
is set up today.
We have Web Properties.
That's where all the user
interaction data is collected.
That's the level it's
collected at.
And then we have profiles, and
profiles basically act as
views of that data.
So you can have one maybe
for marketing.
You might have one for sales, or
certain filters apply that
you want to have different views
of your web property
user interaction data.
What's been introduced with
cost data upload is custom
data sources.
So this resource kind of
acts as representing
external data sources.
You could have a single or
multiple external data sources
per custom data source.
It's up to you.
You can have multiple
custom data
sources on your web property.
I would say, as a best practice,
I would create a
custom data source per
external data source.
It's just a little bit easier
to manage, and it allows you
to kind of separate data from
across the different sources
that you might have.
It's really important that
you link a profile.
So this, as I showed you
before, when you link
profiles, it enables that
data to be available
within those reports.
If you don't have that linking,
then the cost data
will not show up in reports.
So in this case, we have an
example here where we've
created a custom data source,
and it's linked to two
profiles, profile one
and profile three.
So those two will show data, and
profile two will not show
any cost data from that
custom data source.
In addition to that, we
have what we call
daily upload resources.
These kind of represent the
actual data you've uploaded to
GA on a per-date basis.
So you have one for each
day, a resource,
and these are important.
They store information around
which custom data source they
belong to and also metadata
around recent changes that
have taken place with this
particular resource.
So if someone uploaded to it,
deleted it, you get that kind
of changelog history.
It's part of that resource.
You manage and create custom
data sources within the UI,
and you actually upload cost
data using an API.
You can actually also look at
the history of a daily upload
resource within the UI.
I'll show you that, by
going to the history.
There's a little history
link here.
You can kind of get it.
For that custom data source,
you can see all the changes
that have taking place.
And you can actually get-- per
day, you can see all the
changes that have taken place.
OK, also from a creation
standpoint, in deletion, you
need to be an admin.
So admins, anything with
modification to a resource,
whether it's create or
delete, is admin.
And viewers, just regular users,
can view data, but they
can't do anything
around creating
or deleting or uploading.
So that's important.
OK, so we showed you how
to create a data
source, so let's recap.
We've got our URLs tagged with
campaign tracking parameters.
We've got our CSV file that's
prepared and which was
exported out from the
external source.
We've created a custom
data source
using the web interface.
Now, we actually want to upload
the cost data, and we
use this API to carry
this out.
So here's an example
in Python.
It's pretty simple, actually.
You create a media file
upload object, and you
specify the CSV file.
And then you actually just call
the upload method for the
daily uploads resources.
And you specify a few parameters
that are required,
and you execute that.
And it'll automatically upload
the file for you and respond
with a 200 if successful.
If there was an error,
typically--
I think when people first start
out with this, they get
errors around the file
formatting for the CSV.
The errors are really
descriptive, so they really
help you out in terms
of figuring out what
the problems are.
There's also a few other
operations you can carry out.
You can list which
daily uploads.
This gives you your history
and changes.
You can look up for
a year of history.
You can look at what's
taken place.
And we also have a
delete method.
So if you want to get rid of
data completely, you can
actually delete it out of
the daily resource.
And this is important because
the way the cost data is
stored within GA, it's actually
stored separately
outside of your user
interaction data.
So this is great because you
can kind of upload--
If you?
Want to delete something, it
doesn't actually touch any of
your user interaction data.
So feel free to upload and
delete without any worrying
about corrupting or having
any effect on your user
interaction data that's
already there.
All right, so once you've kind
of done that, and you've
actually successfully uploaded
cost data, and it's been
processed, you'll have the data
available in your reports.
So going back to the start of
our presentation, now, the
magic's happened.
Before, we had zero values
for the cost data.
And you can see now when you've
done it properly, this
actual cost data will
get joined.
In reports that you would
normally see zeroes now show
you the campaign visits are now
joined and associated with
that uploaded cost data, which
gives you all these nice other
additional metrics, calculated
metrics, around margin, ROI,
and things like that.
So now you can do your complete
ROI analysis across
all of your different
paid campaigns.
Reporting is available
a few different ways.
We have the API, of course.
You can continue to use the
core report in API to pull
metrics out.
Like I said before, the
dimensions and measures
haven't changed, so any reports
you might have been
running before will work just
as they did before.
There's no changes to be made.
And then from the web interface,
there's kind of two
main options, which are you can
build a custom report or
there's a new cost analysis
report under Traffic Sources.
The cost analysis report, this
is what it looks like.
It's actually just for
cost data upload.
It was created for that.
And then for custom reports,
let's just see if our data
that I had uploaded has
been processed.
So let's refresh this and,
yes, you can see.
That was the cost data we
uploaded at the start of the
presentation.
It has been joined to my
campaign visits for that
particular keyword,
and we can now see
impressions, clicks, and cost.
And of course, you could do--
there's some calculated metrics,
like cost per click,
and you can add those to
your custom report.
So great, it worked.
So some of the opportunities
are, for developers, you have
an opportunity to build
a connector.
There's kind of two steps
to this, I would say.
There's the initial setup, which
is kind of just creating
custom data source, but then
there's two cases that you
really got to consider.
One is historical upload.
You'll notice when I
did the upload, I
uploaded to actually yesterday.
It was data for the 28th, and
you can actually upload data
all the way back to 2005.
So if you've been tagging your
campaign URLs over the last
seven years, you can actually
go back and export the data
and upload that.
It's a little bit different use
case, because typically
when you export, you're going
to export a large chunk of
data from your system, and then
you have to individually
upload that for each day.
So that initial historic
upload is a little bit
different use case, but the
API really allows you to
automate all that.
And then going forward, there's
an opportunity to
build a connector that pulls
the data down from the
external source automatically
and uploads it to GA.
If you don't really have the
development resources or you'd
just like to get started, we
do have four partners that
have built integrations
using this feature.
Next Analytics, GA Data
Uploader, Analytics Canvas,
and ShufflePoint all have
great integrations.
And depending on your
requirements, I think any one
of them will be able to solve a
lot of different use cases.
So I'd definitely encourage you
to check these out in our
App Gallery.
So to finish up here, we have
just a few resources for you.
We'll include these links at
the bottom of the video for
you, but all of this is
available on our developer
site, which is developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
And we also have the App
Gallery, which is
google.com/analytics/apps.
All right, thank you
very much, and
you can start uploading.
I think if we have
some questions,
we'll take some questions.
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
so taking a
quick look at the Moderator.
We have a few questions.
One of them is from John, who
says he's played around a
little bit with uploading cost
data, and his campaigns don't
seem to be matching up.
Are the UTM parameters
case sensitive?
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah, I think
I touched on this earlier.
So the keyword is normalized to
lowercase no matter what.
So that one, you don't even
have to worry about case.
But for the other ones, you do
have to worry about case
sensitivity.
Those will affect what
gets matched up.
But again, because the data's
stored separately, go ahead,
upload things, and you'll see
if you have a problem, you
simply just delete the data.
It doesn't affect any of your
user interaction data, so
there's no problem there.
MALE SPEAKER: And Andrew asks,
"Are we going to be able to
apply advanced segments to
uploaded cost data?"
PETE FRISELLA: So because you're
uploading aggregate
totals for a day, it's not
on a session basis.
So you can't actually
do the advanced
segments like you would.
It actually acts exactly the
same way that AdWords does
today, which is advanced
segments would not apply for
this particular case.
All right, so thanks very much
for taking the time and
joining me today about learning
about cost data upload.
I'll see you guys next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]